today we have two lessons
and we're gonna learn
a whole bunch of notation and
terminology now i don't know about you
when i hear we're gonna learn notation
and terminology
that sounds really boring so we've got
to learn words and definitions
and what do you what's the point okay so
i thought being that today
we're actually going to learn three
different forms of notation okay we're
going to learn ncr notation first then
we're going to learn sigma notation then
we're gonna learn factorial notation and
do a bit of work with all of those
so today's like notation day so i
thought i'd make a big point about
notation in general and why it's useful
i thought how would i illustrate this
and i thought this is probably the
easiest way
now
you can learn notation
in a couple of different ways right or
with a couple of different frames of
mind
you can learn it from the viewpoint of
someone who has to
learn stuff for a test right and you're
like okay
write it all down put it on flash cards
memorize it blah blah blah
and once i get the test done i can
forget about all of this stuff okay now
that's a very tiresome way of learning
notation or terminology there's another
way of doing it
all of this notation in terminology like
it was all devised by someone who's
trying to understand something and work
with it right annotation terminology
allow you to get at something which you
don't yet have language for
and articulate it and understand and
manipulate it so for example
i've been playing the interesting guitar
for
13 years now okay 13 years this is my
rebellion from um having to learn like
every other good migrant child piano
when i was young and then getting kicked
out after i passed preliminary grade
because my teacher said my fingers are
too short so i said fine forget you
proper classical instrument i'm gonna
pick up the guitar i never look back now
the guitar like every other instrument
out there has loads of terminology and
notation associated with it okay and it
can be quite hard to learn all the
beginning for instance uh if you can see
you've got strings everyone knows
they're called strings that's not very
fancy right um but you've got strings
that that are sort of perpendicular to
these metal bars right and um these
metal bars they're called frets and when
you want to talk about which fret you're
you're wanting to put fingers on you
number them right so we say okay these
strings we go from
top to bottom which seems like oh why is
that in reverse and the reason why is
because the um these strings down here
are higher in note than the strings down
here so that's why it's top to bottom
and then when i say okay here's um
here's my fingers on
you know three different strings i would
describe this as
0 2 2 1 0 0. now that's notation if you
see those numbers and you don't know
what any of that means it's confusing
right but it allows me to describe a
chord and that's just the beginning we
talk about uh major chords and minor
chords and uh bar chords and arpeggios
and all of that stuff
the point is that it unlocks a new
language and things that you can do and
you can make music with it right
so
i want you to keep that in your mind as
you think about why are we learning all
this thing these things it's because um
we're trying to
for lack of a better way of saying we're
trying to make music with something
that's very hard to articulate unless we
have some language to do it okay so i'm
not actually going to teach you any
guitar you know
i'm not good enough to do that
and yeah you're a dog i heard you like
learning so i put a subject in your
subject so you can learn while you learn